ميسي يتصدر محركات البحث بسبب اجتماع سري
واصابه مدافع الهلال السعودي بورم حميد
هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
تفاعل رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
والمعنيون بلعبه كره القدم بكثافه مع خبر
اطلاق الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد
السعودي مشروع الاستثمار والتخصيص للانديه
الرياضيه وذلك بعد اكتمال الاجراءات
التنفيذيه للمرحله الاولى تحقيقا لاهداف
رؤيه السعوديه 2030 في القطاع الرياضي
ويتضمن المشروع في المرحله الحاليه
الموافقه على استثمار شركات كبرى ووجهات
تطوير تنمويه في انديه رياضيه مقابل نقل
ملكيه الانديه اليها وطرح عدد من الانديه
الرياضيه للتخصيص بدءا من الربع الاخير من
العام الجاري
نبقى في السعوديه لكن هذه المره مع خبر
محزن اذا اعلن نادي الهلال عن اصابه
مدافعه الكوري الجنوبي جانج هيونسو بورم
حميد في الغدد اللمفاويه وتوسع للعلاج
لفتره تصل الى اربعه اشهر الهلال نشر صورا
للاعب البالغ من العمر واحد وثلاثين عاما
متمنيا له الشفاء وغاب هيونسو عن تشكيله
الهلال في اخر ثلاث مباريات بالدوري الشهر
الماضي واساهم في فوز الهلال بالدوري
السعودي ثلاث مرات وبدوري ابطال اسيا
مرتين وكاس الملك مرتين والوصول الى نهائي
كاس العالم للانديه
تسابقت الانديه العالميه على توديع نجم
الكره السويديه زلاتان ابراهيموفيتش بعدما
اعلى النار رسميا اعتزاله لاعب كره القدم
في سن الحاديه والاربعين انديه اسم ميلان
واياك وبرشلونه وباريس سان جيرمان
ويوفنتوس كذلك تغنت بمسيره ابره و ودعته
بكلمات مؤثره كما نشرت ايضا صفحه منتخب
السويدي على انستجرام صورا للاعب المعتزل
تحت عنوان الاعظم
تناقلت الصحافه ورواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي فيديو تم تصويره على طريقه
البابرد لاجتماع بين والد ميسي ووكيل
اعماله ورئيس نادي برشلونه لبورتا في منزل
الاخير للبحث عوده البرغوث الى النادي
الكتلوني بعدما ذكرت صحف اسبانيه بان
رابطه الدوري الاسباني وافقت برشلونه من
اجل التعاقد مع النجم الارجنتيني خلال
فتره الانتقالات الصيفيه